I'm Jon Taffer and I'm here to answer
the Internet would you rather make a
penny every time you take a breath or
make 10 cents every time you blink I
don't [ __ ] blink I'll take the penny
a pig's orgasm lasts for over 30 minutes
I want to be a freaking pig a lion can
have sex for over over 50 times a day
which would you rather be I'll take the
50 times certainly yeah of course man
even if it's a minute every time it's 50
minutes it's better than 30 minutes it's
a no brainer got to work a little harder
for it though would you rather everybody
talk about you behind your back or never
talk about you at all talk about me
behind my back I know what you're saying
I'm a prick when you're drunk is it
better to get laid or have an ideal
drunk meal always go for the sex you can
eat later who is the one celebrity you
would want at your funeral Kevin I only
picked you cos you're younger than me so
I assume you'll still be around most of
my friends will be gone by then what is
one rumor true or false you'd want to
spread about yourself just like your
producer I [ __ ] really good maybe it's a
little foster if there were stats
available for every aspect of your life
what once that about yourself would you
want to know I've rescued over a
thousand bars that's a pretty good
statistic over 220 television shows
that's not a bad statistic 91 million
viewers that's not a bad statistic if
only they didn't think I was such a
prick
would you rather go to jail for one year
or go to jail with the Rubik's Cube and
you can when it's done man Rubik's cute
is like freaking hell I think I'll take
the jail without the Rubik's Cube you're
with me on that right no there's nothing
to figure out
absolutely at least the one year in jail
I know that it ends in a year with the
Rubik's Cube there's no land
if you belly if your belly button was a
real button and you could push it once a
day to make anything happen what would
it do the answer is obvious push here
out there come on give me something
tougher if every time you finish sex a
song played which would you want it to
be the eve of destruction would you
rather live in a world where everyone
but you is male or female oh man
you guys forget it I'll take the world
with females no question about it
oh no I'll take it guys how much money
would it take for you to not know how to
read should have to be millions and
millions of dollars at least for me not
to read fifty million hours 100 million
dollars a million a [ __ ] word how's
that if you could pick one celebrity to
have your back in a bar fight who would
you pick on the rock for sure right I
mean you want the rock behind you that
situation that's a no-brainer if you
could live anyone's life with anyone's
body who would it be
well it certainly wouldn't be Portenoy
big cat [ __ ] that PFT the guy's this big
for Christ's sakes
I might go back with the rock what do
you say that's how you answer the
internet guys